today we're gonna be looking at the
national video game museum which is
where I work my name is Connor Clarke
and I'm going to give you a tour of the
museum today it's kind of like cribs
isn't it it's like gaming cribs museum
cribs
I suppose the museum isn't open yet so
it might look a little bit quiet but
it's gonna be very loud because well
video games are quite loud first thing
you see when you get into the museum is
this machine here which is racket okay
this game racket is a rocket ship flying
game it's quite quite simple but it's
slightly complicated and how will you
control the rocket ship so we have a
look here instead of using a normal
controller we've employed a makey makey
to turn various fruits and vegetables
into the controller we feel this
exemplifies what the museum wants to do
which instead of having a kind of a
chronological look at video games from
the start to the end which is great we
actually want to kind of deconstruct and
kind of explode what people might expect
from video games so this is playing
around with what we think your
controller can be so we've pressed the
spoon to start and then we can use the
banana and the orange to actually fly
our rocket and see if we can land on the
blue platform there we're going to crash
but we've got way more to see so let's
not dwell on this too much so the way
the museum is constructed is that we
have different bundles of video games
each tied together by a certain concept
this could be anything really this first
bundle is called you are here which are
all games that have been made in
Sheffield and they've kind of become
super super successful the first one we
see is tangle or edition made by Matt
Phillips this is just a small demo I
used to teach programming a few of the
games on the you are here bundle are
some games from Sumer digital which I
want to be biggest to UK game developer
studios and I'm literally based just
down the road but also we have Zul which
are from Goethe was made by gremlin
graphics which I see a highly highly
influential video
so as a few of the bundle which might be
able to see such as words per minute
which is about typing video games
there's the tough bundle which is all
about really really hard games there's a
brilliant Pongal here which is actually
done in partnership with special effects
a special effect or a charity that's
create controllers for people with
perhaps disabilities physical
disabilities they might not be able to
kind of play games in the to using
traditional controllers so they worked
with Xbox to create this thing right
here this is the Xbox adaptive
controller essentially you can use a 3.5
millimeter input just as you would for
kind of any headphones audio and you can
plug anything in there all all of the
different bones we've got the kind of
the the right d-pad burn the up d-pad
burn the down diva button all across the
kind of the why I think sandy buttons as
well so essentially we can play Forza
horizon using just this choice that they
controlled every aspect of the car and
you can facing this fly around the the
wilderness of Scotland it's brilliant
for people that might have kind of
disabilities and are enables play games
in the traditional ways alongside our
bundles we also have other kind of games
that are really cool and often you can
only play here in the museum one of them
which you can explai at home to think
something a BVB the App Store but not in
this way
it's called int now this is a very large
digital pinball machine
so using inks you can play pinball but
it works with paint and we can come
literally paint on the screen whilst
playing pinball it's really really cool
how it works it's a very very large iPad
you can even see at the top of the
screen there and it's put in this huge
kind of built pinball machine with
buttons on either side and it's it's
amazing it's really really cool I'm no
good at pinball there we go
so one of the missions of the museum is
to collect and preserve gaming ephemera
and gaming memorabilia from all across
planet video game history so we have a
kind of quite traditional Museum things
and they have a big glass cabinets where
we have all of our what we think a
really kind of influential gaming
objects such as the Magnavox Odyssey
which is the first ever video game
console it was actually released in 1972
was made by Ralph Baer we have some
special editions here the the Master
Chief helmet is a particularly favorite
one of mine but stuff like this before I
put boy and the Call of Duty special
editions we have a handheld gaming
exhibit here with various game boys but
also kind of other things such as the
barcode battler Astro Wars smaller kind
of video game consoles we also have a
very very pretty playstation portable
that is probably one of my favorite
items in the entirety in the museum so
this is all but kind of a small part of
our collection really we have a lot of
other things that we're storing in
Nottingham in one of our big kind of
collections that we're hosting with the
universities over there this is our vs.
cabinet which is all about kind of
Mortal Kombat or Street Fighter 2 which
one were you were you Super Nintendo or
Master System or Mega Drive I personally
was a Super Nintendo the snares with
Street Fighter 2 however I get a lot of
things out here in the museum but you
know and then we have a controller
section as well all about different
controllers we have including some
wireless Atari controllers which is
really really cool and from the kind of
the 70s one of the big flagship exhibits
we have in the museum is platform 14
which is the all of these kind of huge
screens we have along the side here this
exhibit explores the concept of porting
a video game and the video game we've
chosen to start with is Donkey Kong so
we have the original kind of arcade
version of Donkey Kong right here it's a
very pretty looking game released kind
of in 1981 in the arcades but it was so
successful that everybody wanted a piece
of it and they wanted to port it to each
one of the different consoles so what
we've done is we've got other versions
of the ports of that game playable along
these screens so alongside there was an
arcade we have the nez version we have
the commodore 64 version we have the
gameboy version
via
twenty six hundred and seventy eight
hundred as well and my particular
favorite is this one the trs-80 version
when you compare this to the original
arcade is vastly different in regards to
kind of graphics and also in regards to
the sound but it still plays and feels
like Donkey Kong which i think is a
testament to the nature of the port I
don't want to show myself work so we're
actually not very good at dog song it's
incredibly difficult game so no she got
more running on the same kind of
controller I mean who's that is that
tricky thing to do not particularly
notice these versions are all emulated
we actually have a mixture of emulated
games and games running on their natural
hardware such as the Mario & Sonic
exhibit right here the reason we do that
is because we're able to play around
with games a little bit more for example
with this kind of screen here if we were
to have each of these running on their
original hardware's they all have
different resolutions that they play out
and it's not easy to kind of compare the
differences so if we emulate them we're
very easily able to compare what are the
graphical differences of each game this
cabinet kind of explores why we need a
video game museum for example we do have
the pre-owned prices of some FIFA games
here that's obviously last year's
installment fee for 19 to 25 pounds but
as soon as you get to the next one a
flat fee for 18 it drops significantly
and by the time we get to be 15 they're
worth pennies we don't think video games
even or video games are worth pennies we
think they all should be saved we also
have a lot of our broken stuff here
obviously because we have lots and lots
of people coming in playing all of our
games we go through a lot of controllers
and a lot of hardware very quickly
oftentimes you're able to recycle those
are users in other ways but sometimes we
just keep the broken ones and then we
exhibit them as well on this back wall
we do have a bunch of arcade machines as
well wouldn't be a video game museum
without a few kind of classic arcade
cabinets such as space invaders we have
a Miss pac-man and another Donkey Kong
just for good measure
one thing we really like is this cabin
over here which is dancing stage fusion
or I was known as DDR in other places
outside of the UK so it's really fun
about this is that one time it broke and
we had to get inside and kind of go play
around with it and make see if we can
fix it and we found as we're playing
around with it that there was a slot for
a PlayStation 2 memory card and upon
closer inspection we actually found that
this entire machine is essentially a
commercial ps2 running inside of it it's
no different to an office to do chemical
controllers in you can plug in other
memory cards with your high scores from
other machines yeah but then we get over
here which is probably my favorite part
of the museum it's called the lab
because it is about exploring what makes
a videogame and kind of distilling it
down so we do have a lot of old
development units which you might have
seen before but all really interesting
there's no Nintendo dolphin and the
Gamecube test kit there at DSS gear we
do have the old PlayStation 2
development kit as well funny story
behind this one this was originally from
free radical which is a studio that was
based in Nottingham in the UK this
machine itself actually was used to make
the original timesplitters game on
PlayStation 2 so I took a picture of
this unit and posted it on social media
from the museum because I thought it was
really fun and it's a cool little
looking unit and we had someone I used
to work for free radical comments on
that suite saying oh what's that one of
the units that was stolen I was like oh
what's of stolen really why I didn't
collected this this machine so I had no
idea if it's stolen or not but there
were a few development kits that were
stolen around a similar time this isn't
one of them I made sure of it but there
was a panic in my chest that we were
holding stolen goods in the museum for a
split second I find out as well as
exhibiting the past and
of videogames we also want to have a
quick peek into the future of games here
at the museum as well so we have this
section here which is all about in
development and currently unreleased
games essentially we as a museum reach
out to independent creators of video
games small teams and we say we really
like your work how would you feel about
is exhibiting it in a museum so we can
see a game in progress
these include teams such as aerobat
super luminary which is a fascinating
little game one of my favorite ones are
these in development games is something
like drink more glut which is this fun
little limbic style party game which is
really fun and we get so many people
coming in and playing these games that
was such a fun time and what we can do
is ask those people about feedback on
these games so if they really liked ring
Robert or or maybe they didn't liked an
original verb we can take that on board
and then we can even feed that back to
the creators as well y velocity to eight
and then we going to enter this infinite
loop here so we're going to add the
players X velocity to Z zero and add the
players Y velocity to d1r then we gonna
jump back up and we're gonna get the
problem is there you have to go right
from the very end of the game which in
chess you you can't do it there's just
too many possibilities
[Music]